i almost forgot to ask you
about one of the most exciting aspects
of ethereum i mean it's non-technical i
think it's a
it's a societal it's social which is uh
nfts so uh what do you think
what do you think about the explosion of
nfts in the recent
months uh especially in the art world
and beyond and what does the future look
like so this is maybe
the social impact on the world on on the
individual creators of all kinds
like is that something you've actually
expected to see
and that is having this kind of impact
and beyond
what do you think will happen in the
in the digital space within fts in
virtual reality and gaming all those
kinds of things
i was definitely surprised by like nfts
in particular
like i even actually i think might be on
record somewhere on some tech conference
panel like they were asking you know
um it was one of those overrated or
underrated sections and asked about nfts
and i thought
and i said like hey i think nfts are
overrated yeah and you know in
retrospect that turned out to be quite
wrong
um i think like i guess i just
personally
can't really relate to this concept of
like spending a lot of money on a thing
like there's nothing you know there's no
queer kind of
understanding of why that thing would uh
maintain its value right um uniqueness
of a thing
having value right exactly that's
like i definitely am like cannot really
understand you know the psychology
behind like buying you know paying 200
000
for original art painting i'd be like
you know if i had a mansion just like
give me photocopies of everything
you can hang three photocopies of the
the mona lisa
well i would even have the mona lisa i
think i'd probably just like have some
neon cats or something
that's one thing where mathematics or
theoretical computer science cannot
formalize why the heck nfts are valuable
exactly but the thing that
i and that makes me very happy about the
space now that it has happened
is that i mean this gets back to the
conversation that we had at the
beginning right like i'm
interested in this concept of
decentralized uh public goods funding
right like i want
things that are good and valuable to as
much as possible
also be things that can you know
economically sustain the people who
produce them
right because if you don't have that
then either the public goods just don't
get produced at all
or people make like centralized versions
that have some of the properties and try
to be substitutes but actually just like
concentrate control in a very small
group right
and you know both of those things are
not very nice so
the nice thing about nfts would be well
if you're an artist and you can
just mint nfts and this is a source of
revenue then like great that's another
stream of revenue for
you know creative work that often does
still get get underfunded and that's
amazing
you